yeah
Hodgins Hutton was good to Yvonne you
come over that's it it's not like to do
just tells the guru I did just get my
face on him you to keep 15 uh-huh I'll
be right there
friends we must get debug immediately I
can't even look at you into the jet what
do I have to get my own bags whatever
James Harden what am I going to do with
you talk to me what do you want to be
don't move
nailed it is that it we have unlit just
big guy
just coffee little bit oh no my Beatrice
get your beards but don't you stop
blowing this way why are you yelling at
the beer I've made it Angry
I'm sorry bill we're descending off some
negative wave it is all positive is it
well I hope that's true
Golden Sun gold I thought you here to
fix month I'm going to this event but
it's a whole experience I got something
we can try cool hmm
there was good oh we could lay down some
tracks racing through the cookie jar do
you ever hear that into the cookie jar
and it goes straight every time never
hurt them never that
hey Rockets Chuck's us out cookie jar
and dared me luck James's brilliant
that's a that's a great idea
relaxed just did me brushing brush but
have to be amazed this your beer guru
maybe my name is first-time tastic your
eyebrows they are like shaking hands
well done
very good
no you should see yourself in the mirror
total difference trust me oh yeah yeah
do a little video today we will yo yo yo
yo yo yo yo yo yo yo Oh
Oh
yeah